[Musique]
nous sommes le 8 novembre 2016 bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 c les
invités rencontres avec celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dans le département
aujourd'hui vous vous entendrez olivier
paréja le responsable dans les yvelines
de la formation europe ecologie les
verts nous reviendrons avec lui sur la
désignation pour la présidentielle de
cet homme yannick jadot le député
européen est arrivé en tête avec 54,1
25% des voix lors du second tour de la
primaire écologiste
et puis florian beaufils nous présentera
le concert play for humanity vendredi
samedi prochain une douzaine de groupes
qui vont se produire sur la scène du
scarabée à la verrière un festival en
mémoire des victimes du terrorisme un an
après le drame du bataclan bonsoir à
tous les deux et bienvenue en plateau on
va commencer par de la politique les
militants europe ecologie les verts ont
donc tranché et yannick jadot sera leur
candidat et donc votre candidat aussi à
l'élection présidentielle il recueille
54 25 % des voix olivier parages est ce
que c'est une vraie surprise je pense
que la première surprise était d'abord
au premier tour l'élimination de cécile
duflot pense que certain nombre de gens
ne s'y attendait pas
donc là lui après au deuxième tour
yannick jadot ou michèle rivasi on était
dans le on était dans les écologistes
qui avait été chez greenpeace le plus
dans la partie militante associative de
l'écologie donc c'était un peu homogène
donc après voilà il c'est yannick il est
sorti en premier votre choix personnel
se portait plus verts cécile duflot est
aussi une part de déception ou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui non ça c'est d'ores et
déjà oublier en fait c'est sur la
campagne je pense et ce qui a été très
bien pendant sept ans cette campagne de
primaires que ce soit le premier ou le
second tour c'est que et on l'a vu dans
les différents débats qui sont passés
d'un sur les télévisions sur les radios
le projet écologiste était porté par les
quatre candidats de la même façon après
on était sur des personnalités sur des
parcours personnels mais mais je pense
que on va avoir aucun état d'âme qui que
ce soit en particulier dans les yvelines
et les écologistes avec qui j'ai parlé
on aura aucun état d'âme à ce qu'il
vienne in shadow comme on aurait dû
suivre chacun des candidats qui avait sa
part
sa personnalité voilà ça veut dire que
la personnalité et le fait d'être une
ancienne ministre jouer en la défaveur
de cécile duflot quand même je pense
qu'il ya eu un choix qui a été
relativement claire puisqu'elle a été
éliminée dès le premier tour qui était
de dire bon ben on veut changer on veut
plutôt des militants associatifs des
gens qui n'ont pas été dans le moule de
la politique nationale et donc
cécile duflot s'est fait retoquer entre
guillemets sur sur son passé politique
dans est peut-être ce sont son parcours
de ministre peut-être lé c'était elle
qui était plus proche du milieu
politique habituelle donc là y ait une
rupture les écologistes veulent autre
chose et c'est aussi peut-être comme ça
qu europe ecologie les verts peut
s'ouvrir sur tous les écologistes qui
sont pas dans les partis politiques même
si europe ecologie les verts et le parti
de référence aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
d'écologistes qui sont proches qui sont
sympathisants et y en avait beaucoup qui
ont voté à la primaire d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui europe ecologie les verts
c'est 3 % dans les sondages pour la
présidentielle le plus dur commence
effectivement nomme c'était c'était
aussi peut-être l'avantagé entre
guillemets de cécile duflot c'est
d'avoir une plus grande notoriété que
yannick jadot mais quand je vois que la
semaine dernière gagné jadot a
interpellé ils vont car au parlement
européen sur les traités transatlantique
et que la vidéo a été visionnée plus
d'un million de fois je me dis que assez
rapidement on devrait revenir à
plus que curry 3% vous parler
aujourd'hui mais la campagne s'est
encore ne fait que commencer en tous les
cas la campagne ne fait que commencer et
la première étape enfin maintenant que
la désignation a été fait c'est aussi de
recueillir suffisamment de parrainage
pour pouvoir se présenter et la
difficulté supplémentaire parce que vous
ne manquez pas cette année europe
écologie ce sera tout de même de trouver
ces parrainages parce que les
socialistes vont pas forcément vous
donner un coup de pouce cette année
c'est possible c'est possible mais d'un
autre côté je pense par exemple ont
crédité nicolas hulot de plus de 10% je
pense qu'il aurait eu aucun mal à
trouver ses parrainages et c'est fort
possible que yannick jadot par son
parcours puis celui aussi de montrer une
autre facette de l'écologie qui fera que
certain nombre de grands électeurs
pourront donner leur signature c'est
aujourd'hui le jour des publics voyez
enfin cette fois-ci par rapport à la
précédente qui va être public et ça
aussi c'est quelque chose intéressant
pour voir les positionnements des uns
des autres qui deviennent plus quelque
chose qu'on fait secrètement ça sera
beaucoup plus officiel et ça rendra les
choses encore plus compliquées sans
doute aussi pas du sud dans le cadre des
jeux et des différentes alliances parce
qu'il ya aussi des calculs politiques au
delà de ça j'en viens à yannick jadot il
est plutôt issu de l'ailé droite du
parti c'est comme ça qu'il est présenté
est-ce que ça va avoir une influence ou
pas donc c'est tout à l'heure que mail
droite pour vous ça représentait pas
grand chose finalement on a dit alors
j'ai pas l'impression que cette primaire
était vraiment axé sur l'ailé droite sur
l'ailé gauche je sais pas si ça a
vraiment un sens par rapport à
l'écologie donc là clairement il yannick
jadot porte le programme d'europe
écologie et verts s'est donc on va
retrouver tout ce qui concerne les
énergies renouvelables la santé
l'alimentation
on va vraiment retombée sur les
fondamentaux de l'écologie donc je pense
qu'on va être plus dans l'écologie que
dans le petit jeu droite gauche et après
par rapport par exemple au parti
socialiste dont vous parliez
précédemment il est clair que on ne va
pas faire d'alliance avec le parti
socialiste c'était ma question d'après
pas de participation à la primaire de la
gauche toute façon il ya des ados
l'avait dit ne voulais pas non non
partagé vous pensez que c'est une bonne
idée qu'il faut pas à participer à cette
primaire de la gauche dans l'élite
organiser enfin il ya encore beaucoup
d'inconnues aussi mais dans la mesure où
c'est une primaire du parti socialiste
et des composantes proches les petits
partis qui sont autour de lui et qu'ils
sont au gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est
clairement pas notre ligne politique je
pense qu' en 2011 on avait fait un
accord avec le parti socialiste pour les
élections de 2012 qui n'a pas été
respectée sur de nombreux points que ce
soit le nucléaire que ce soit
de nombreux points cela fiscalité
écologique par exemple des choses de ce
type là qui n'ont pas du tout été
respectée donc c'est assez logique qu'on
se réinscrivent pas dans le même
processus et un rapprochement avec
l'extrême gauche peut-être avec jean luc
mélenchon le parti communiste c'est
possible enfin je pense que cette
élection on est parti pour défendre les
couleurs de l'écologie donc le verre est
donc peut vraiment de façon autonome de
façon à faire réentendre les problèmes
projet les projets écologistes le projet
écologiste qui qui est sur la santé sur
l'agriculture sur les sur les transports
collectifs sur la fiscalité
aymeric durable un vrai un prêt avec un
vrai risque malgré tout c'est celui
d'avoir des difficultés financières
encore plus importante pour la formation
parce qu'europe écologie aujourd'hui ils
rencontrent des difficultés en fonction
du résultat ça pourrait devenir encore
plus problématique je pense qu'on peut
arriver à faire une campagne qui ne va
pas et qui ne campagne monstrueuse nous
n'aurons pas les problèmes
nicolas sarkozy en faisant des meetings
monstrueux on paie par greg anderson à
lyon pour faire la campagne nous avons
révisé de l'accord que nos idées et donc
on va on va être sur une campagne
dimensionné par rapport au budget qu'on
aura nécessairement oui vous avez évoqué
le programme justement un mot sur le
programme et cette question liée à
l'actualité aussi yannick jadot qui
propose de créer un fbi européens
appellent à davantage de coopération
dans la police le renseignement la
justice il a aussi déclaré il faut
cesser d'être copain copain avec
l'arabie saoudite ou le qatar qui
exporte une vision fascinante de la
religion d'accord avec tout ça alors
qu'on a droit justement dans l'actualité
de ce l'anniversaire du 13 novembre mais
je pense que yannick jadot a aussi dit
par exemple que le fichier qui était en
train de nous préparer le gouvernement
pendant pendant le pont de la toussaint
était quelque chose qui n'était du
contrôle de l'état sur les citoyens
alors que lui voulait redonner de la
démocratie et à linverse du contrôle des
citoyens sur l'état donc je pense
qu'effectivement on va se retrouver sur
beaucoup de choses merci olivier parent
et j'avoue rester en plateau on va
aborder justement cette question du
terrorisme mais à travers une toute
autre problématique c'est celle du
souvenir de la mémoire nous poursuivons
effectivement avec ce concert organisé
au scarabée à la verrière au plus tôt
ses concerts florian beaufils vous êtes
l'organisateur de play for humanity 11
12 novembre au scarabée à la verrière le
public va pouvoir assister une douzaine
de représentations parmi lesquelles
celle des fatals des fatals picards
pardon no one is innocent ça aussi qui
seront présents c'est un festival au
profit de l'association des victimes du
terrorisme
l'origine de ce concert pourquoi avoir
voulu l'organiser qu'est ce qui vous a
motivé vous personnellement pour vous
impliquer et bien tout simplement une
volonté comme la vie du personnel moi
j'ai touché mon com 90% la population
peut-être 95%
j'ai voulu faire cette action pour
redire maintenant on ne vous oublie pas
ça fait un an ces récents mais en ce
qu'on veut faire c'est continuer
pérenniser l'événement et dire qu'on est
toujours là pour entretenir cette ce
soir cette nuit mois concert 11 et 12
néanmoins les animations sont prévues
dès le jeudi tous dès le 10 et ça va se
prolonger jusqu'au dimanche alors en
dehors des concerts des 11 et 12 alors
en dehors du concert violon et 12 donc
il y a le jeu d'histoire un voisin
bretonneux
il y à une soirée étudiante organisée
donc parler d'une étudiante il par
l'association acquis cros avec qui on a
fait un partenariat est donc le dimanche
à l'église de maurepas entre 15h30 et
17h il ya trois groupes de musique 7,8
en choeur enjoy et accords et nie donc
voilà c'est tout c3 c4 saurait ça va
c'est quelle journée de concerts sont
pour ceux ci en aide aux victimes du
terrorisme à quoi vont servir ces fonds
pour l'association comment intervient
dans cette association justement et bien
eux et ce avec de lutter contre la
radicalisation
déjà en amont et ensuite ils sont là
pour comment dirais-je aider les
personnes les victimes à monter les
dossiers à avancer et puis je viens
soutien psychologique qui est très très
important qui est fait par ce par cette
association donc c'est pour ça on a fait
le choix de l'association française des
victimes du terrorisme et surtout un
autre show enfin une autre raison qui a
fait qu'on a qu'on s'est tourné vers
cette association là parce qu'ils aident
toutes les victimes du terrorisme
on vient même mon malheureusement dans
les années 80 90 et déjà des actions est
donc là aussi on est là pour leur dire
qu'on ne vous oublie pas et puis cette
problématique qui est d'actualité qui
fait débat en ce moment le barreau de
paris a réclamé le lundi 7 novembre que
deux nouveaux préjudice soit indemnisé
pour les victimes du terrorisme
ces dernières demandent aussi des
améliorations dans la prise en charge
médicale là aussi l'association
intervient quel regard vous portez sur
c'est sur ces demandes du barreau de
paris qu'on élargisse la prise en charge
des victimes celles qui sont victimes
sicot logique aussi c'est très important
il le faut parce que quand je vous
disais
quand on a été témoin de ce genre
d'événement
s'avoue travail c'est quelque chose a
été confronté à la mort a été confronté
c'est pas quelque chose de naturel c'est
pas quelque chose que l'on vit tous
forcément tous les jours et heureusement
on va dire on n'est pas en état de
guerre donc ce sont des événements
marquants et on doit être considérée
comme victime comme malheureusement une
personne qui a été touché dans son corps
et mon et personnes qui ont perdu des
personnes proches on ne doit pas y avoir
une hiérarchisation delà de la victime
de avoir ni
moi je n'ai pas été touchée par moi même
donc je peux pas juger il devrait avoir
une grille inégalités voilà pour toutes
ces personnes et parmi les différents
groupes qui vont se produire je pense
aux fatals picards qui eux ont été
touchés puisqu'ils ont perdu un membre
de leur entourage de l'organisation
technique tout à fait madame jardin donc
voila mon bien sûr quand j'ai contacté
les fatals picards tout de suite ils ont
dit oui comme une nouvelle naissance se
sont déclarés le jury du bataclan voilà
ils ont été très touchés et ont bien sûr
sans problème
vous avez fait beaucoup de mal à les
convaincre non comment ça s'est passé
pour les autres groupes no one is
innocent par exemple on peut citer un
crossfire au chili aussi l'esprit du
clan contre ceux qui connaissent alors
au banal boys band c'est une copine qui
nous a présenté bon j'étais bien j'ai
médias leur musique et puis lors on va
dire leur ambiance dont jaune albecq au
chili lé 10 il dîne donc c'est ben je
crois c'est lors d'une première
interview chez vous qui m'a dit ah bah
tiens ma grande va bien participer au
projet donc bien sûr mail avec un
problème était la bienvenue puis après
c'est par réseau et puis bon bien
certains groupes comme les mycoses
qu'ils m'expliquent du plan ou contrôler
stars ce sont des copains ou des groupes
que j'aime bien personnellement 20
livres s'y intéresse de venir participer
il ya aucun problème pour réserver il ya
un site internet qui s'affiche vous avez
aussi votre page facebook play for
humanity à cette adresse mail avait
aussi s'afficher mais je leur donne play
for humanity la 78e
gmail.com il est encore possible de
réserver pour samedi pour dimanche bien
sûr mais au niveau des tarifs si on peut
faire un petit point alors mon jeudi
soir c'est les gens donnent ce qu'ils
veulent c'est voilà les étudiants
donnent ce qu'ils veulent le vendredi
samedi donc ses 25 euros mais grâce donc
au support et puis
là vous avez décidé de faire un geste
dont on va dire pour noël un
téléspectateur qui nous suivra voire une
réduction ou en tout à fait de 5 euros
et six feet appelle tout simplement ça
la billetterie tv fils en
correctionnelle et puis donc autrement
vous mettre à l association
d'associations elle avait pété donc
conventionnés tv fils tout attaché lors
de votre réservation sur le site
internet qui cette affiche et vous aurez
une réduction de 5 euros il est encore
possible de réserver on donne quelques
uns des groupes no one is innocent les
fatals picards nous serons présents
aussi pour réaliser un reportage et puis
pour ceux qui ne pourront pas venir mais
on vous incite à y aller pour soutenir
tout de même la démarche compte rendu et
dès le lundi sur nos antennes merci
beaucoup d'être venu merci à grand
plateau nous en parler merci olivier
paréja également c'est la fin du set 8
elle est invitée rendez vous demain aux
horaires habituels pour une nouvelle
séquence avec celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité voulait dire un dernier mot
merci à quelques jours près vous étiez
pas loin merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]